>>> Fox faces a threat from the
multibillion dollar defamation
case.
That is the headline from CNN
business this morning after that
explosive legal filing that came
into public view this week.
These are some of the biggest
revelations if you missed it.
The billionaire owner Rupert
Murdoch conceded that four of
the main hosts on the airwaves
including Shawn hannity and Lou
Dobbs endorsed false statements.
They said they would have been
stronger in denouncing the lies
in hindsight.
Half of what trump is saying is
bs and damaging.
He also admitted hannity was,
quote, privately disgusted by
trump but scared to lose
viewers.
Fox's legal team says the quotes
coming out don't tell the full
story.
They call the lawsuit dubious
and cited the first amendment as
a defense.
Joining us to talk about this is
renowned first amendment
attorney Lloyd Abrams.
Floyd, I want to start with you.
You, who have argued before the
supreme court many times, you
believe this is land mark case.
>> I think it's an extremely
threatening case to fox.
I think it's a very important
case.
There hasn't been one, I would
say, involving media, not just
broadcast.
Which so threatened the
legitimacy of an enormous player
in terms of informing the
American public.
>> Do you think on that point
that it could have the potential
to move the malice bar?
Is that what you're saying?
>> No.
I think I'm -- on that front
it's just ironic that it's the
conservatives.
>> The other way around.
>> That want to move the bar.
I don't think it will be -- I'm
hopeful at least it's not going
to be moved.
Fox is quite understandably
clutching to it:it's a raft in a
sea.
It's very important to their
defense.
>> Let's get to that.
I want to talk about the
audience here.
You're making the point that we
talked about earlier in our
conversation where I said this
was -- this has more than just
an impact on what happens with
Fox News.
What will the viewers think?
That's all very important.
But this is first amendment.
Freedom of the press.
You have a news organization
allegedly in collusion with
political players here lying to
their audiences, potentially, or
at least in many people's eyes
and court's eyes.
Starting an insurrection.
There is so much at stake here.
As you said this is one of the
biggest cases involving the
media than I can remember in
recent history.
This is not just small potatoes.
>> No.
It's big time.
Look, fox is big time.
The amount of viewers it has,
the impact it has on the public.
And here's a case -- I can't
help but think that any new
lawyer and I'll bet any of the
old lawyers said to someone at
fox maybe this will be a good
case to put behind you.
Maybe there is some way to set
this will consistent with
rationality?
I mean if they're asking for
blank, of course, you won't do
it.
>> Why isn't that happening?
>> I don't think we know.
If I had to guess, I'll bet
there had been talks.
I don't know that.
It's inconceivable to me that as
savvy, whatever else one says
about the fox people, as savvy
as they are that it hasn't
occurred to them that they would
really be in much better shape
if they could just say we paid
the money.
We didn't do anything wrong.
But, you know, it's over.
>> Yeah.
>> You worked in the trump white
house.
You know the influence and
communication that there often
was between trump himself and
trump officials.
What do you think about the
political fallout?
Despite having direct insight, I
was very shocked to hear
about -- to read about Rupert
Murdoch sharing an ad with a
former white house adviser.
I didn't know about that.
I would be surprised if that was
something that was widely known.
Take for example they would like
to host a primary debate.
Who is to say that fox won't put
the finger on the scale in favor
of the candidates that gets them
the best ratings.
This comes down to, there is a
quote where he said it is not
red or blue, its green.
It's about making money.
So there is a lot of potential
fallout, I think, for both the
fox audience and the people who
consume that information.
But also this is a scary part.
Most fox viewers are not going
to hear about.
This they're not aware.
I've been texting family members
in that space just -- are you
aware of this?
Do you know you're being lied
to?
>> Let's play Howard Kurtz, a
fox employee who anchors the
media show every week.
Here's what he said about being
muzzled.
Here he was.
>> Some of you have been asking
why I'm not covering the
dominion voting machine lawsuit
against fox involving the
unproven claims of election
fraud in 2020.
It's absolutely a fair question.
I believe I should be covering
it.
It's a major media story given
my role here at fox.
But the company decided that as
part of the organization being
sued, I can't talk about it or
write about it at least for now.
>> They don't know.
They're not going to hear about
it.
>> And good for Howard Kurtz for
telling the truth.
People have been penalized or
asked by senior people
executives to penalize people.
I think if a very serious
reporter at fox who is just
trying to do her job fact
checking it takes bravery to go
on the airwaves and say they're
muzzling me.
>> He covers the media.
Do you think that -- is that
ligit?
?
There is so much at stake here.
We can't have you discussing
just in case just because?
Sh.
>> Anything he says will be held
against them.
I get why they don't want him to
speak.
That then goes into brief of
dominion.
As even the fox's own ex has
said that.
And acknowledge that.
And they're in a situation now
where almost any commentary and
e-mails or the like which surely
they must have learned by now
that they are turned over in
litigation.
They're suffering from what they
said to each other in writing.
It is harmful to them and the
litigation.
And it's not -- I said this and
then someone else said, I don't
remember it that way.
Here it is.
This is what they said.
They're able to be enough --
>>, no I was going to say.
Donald Trump is a big part of
this.
He started to create the
narrative after he spread the he
lies that news max is where we
should go.
What America news network is
where true believers are going.
So there was a sense of fear
within fox that they were going
to lose market share to the
outlets.
The reality is that they never
even picked up enough that in
major way affected the very high
viewership that Fox News had.
You can just see the fear he
instilled in the big time hosts,
the prime time hosts.
And I just want to say, there is
a lot of really good journalists
at fox.
I don't have any major problems.
Prime time is where they make
the money.
It descended into conspiracy
mongering.
It is basically anything to get
people to tune in and drive
viewership.
>> Wow.
That's interesting that not even
a straight forward news story
about this is what is happening,
dominion is accusing Fox News
and Fox News responded this way.
It could be a straight forward
news story without any
commentary.
>> They don't want it to exist.
>> It does.
>> My favorite Abrams.